- What's the longest word?
Answering that question is a little more
complicated than just counting letters
but, by that metric, the longest contender
is the technical name
for the protein titin.
It has a 189,819 letters
and it looks like this.
(tape winding)
If you wanna hear what it sounds like,
there's actually a YouTube video of that.
You'll just need about 3
and a half hours to spare.
- (in a foreign language)
- But there's a big
asterisk at the end of those
180,000 letters because
most linguists don't really
consider this thing a word,
more like a verbal formula.
The longest word in a
major English dictionary
is
pneumonoultramicroscopicsilicovolcanoconiosis
which means a lung disease
caused by the inhalation
of volcanic ash. But as
the entry points out,
this was deliberately invented to be long
which kind of puts it in the
same category as other made up
mouthfuls like
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious.
We could just say the
longest word is grandmother,
with an infinite number
of "great-"s ahead of it
(glass shattering)
but that would be
uncharacteristically simplistic
for a linguistic show.
If we're going to find
a more satisfying answer
to this question, we'll have to dig deeper
into what the word, word really means.
(easy music)
- Otherwords.
- If you listen to a conversation
in an unfamiliar language
it's pretty much impossible
to pick out individual words.
- (in a foreign language)
- And sometimes the same
goes for your own language.
If you say to your roommate,
aminagothstorjwannything?
Are you really aware of all the individual
words you're cramming together?
Does your brain or your
roommate's actually care
where one word ends and another begins?
Some languages allow you
to pack whole phrases
and sentences into one
word like this Turkish word
that means as though you
happen to have been from among
those whom will not be able to easily
make a make of unsuccessful ones.
and this German word that
means the law delegating
the monitoring of the labeling of beef.
We can do a little of this in English,
in a "this-technically-counts-as-a-word-
-but-who-on-earth-would-ever-call-it-that?" kind of way.
We can also glue words
together to make compound words,
but rarely more than two at a time.
And whether they get a space
can feel pretty arbitrary.
Living room: space. Bedroom: no space.
Tennis ball: space. Baseball: no space.
That's why the whole concept of words
is sometimes considered to
be primarily orthographic
(typewriter keys clicking)
which means it only matters
when you're writing it down.
After all I'm not thinking about
spaces when I say the words
front yard, and backyard
but if I type them,
spell check will let me
know there's a difference.
(keyboard keys clicking)
(easy song ends)
So are words things
that exist only on paper
and not in our minds?
Maybe not.
Many linguists think that what
really makes a word, a word,
has to do less with how it's written
and more with how our brains process it.
When you hear the sentence,
"Cheetahs can run faster than lions"
your brain analyzes the order
of the words to determine
the meaning of the sentence
but you don't need to
analyze the words themselves,
you just know them.
Cheetah, is a sound you
memorized a long time ago
because everyone agrees that it
means a big cat, with spots,
that can run really, really fast.
Your brain doesn't need
to know why it means that,
it just does.
If we had to analyze individual words
the way we analyze sentences,
language would become a slog
of incomprehensibilities.
It's actually been tried.
In the 1600's the philosopher
Bishop John Wilkins
proposed a universal language in which the
meanings of the words were
baked into their spellings.
He tried to divide every
concept in the universe
into categories and subcategories
and assigned them all letters and slots.
For example, the Wilkish
word for dog was zita.
A Z in the first slot meant animals,
a subsequent I meant four-legged
then T for European canines
and finally, A for the
specific species, dog.
You can probably see why
this didn't catch on.
The sheer amount of mental
computation required
to understand one word,
would be ridiculous.
A child raised to speak Wilkish,
would have probably tossed
all that nonsense aside
and just memorized zita
the way you and I memorized dog.
Even the origins of relatively
new words quickly become irrelevant.
There is probably a short time in 2004
when people were aware that a podcast
was a broadcast that you
listen to on your ipod
but our brains don't
bother with all that today.
It's called a podcast because
that's just what it is.
The internationalization of
the word is further proof
that no one really cares
where the sounds came from.
This word violates the same
rule that Wilkins' zita did.
It tries to explain its
meaning within itself.
The power of words
comes from the fact that
they're memorized not analyzed.
Because we've all agreed on
a shared mental dictionary,
the actual sounds
themselves can be arbitrary.
No one needs to bother
with this monstrosity
because we've already agreed
upon a much easier word
for the same disease: silicosis.
But just because something's memorized
doesn't necessarily mean that it's short.
Many linguists consider
compound words with spaces
like ice cream, roller coaster
and high school to be single
words because that's how our
brains interpret them, as
indivisible units that we
memorize to mean a specific thing.
Some linguists push this idea even further
claiming that idioms and cliches
should also count as words.
When we use phrases like
"fly off the handle",
"bite the bullet" or "jump the shark",
we're not concerned with their origins
or the literal meanings of their parts.
We're just counting on our
listener having the same
memorized entry in
their mental dictionary.
This is why many English
dictionaries don't include
that other famously long word,
antidisestablishmentarianism.
Originally the word was coined
for a political movement
of 19th-century Britain
that was opposed to,
you guessed it, disestablishmentarianism
but it has so little
relevance to our lives today
that it's just not a part
of our shared vocabulary
anymore.
(glass shattering)
How do we judge whether a word is
part of our shared vocabulary?
That really depends on who
the speakers and listeners are
but if a word were used casually
in conversation or say a
YouTube video and it didn't
set off on any alarm bells
"but that would be uncharacteristically
"simplistic for a linguistic show.
"Language would become a slog
of incomprehensibilities.
"The internationalization of the word
"is further proof that no one."
These are three of the longest,
non-spaced, non-hyphenated
English words that are
considered "in common usage"
If these slip past your
ear without slowing down
your comprehension, then we could safely
call these part of your shared vocabulary
and strong contenders for the longest,
commonly used word in English, to you.
As with all things human,
there are very few, hard
boundaries in language.
What one person considers a word,
might be a phrase to someone else
and pure nonsense to someone else.
Maybe it's best not to
think of a word as something
printed in a book with ink,
or on a screen in pixels
but as a unique power of the human mind
that only works because it's
shared with everyone else.
(easy music)
What's the longest word?
Wow, so cool.
What's the longest...
These are my words, coming
out of my mouth, okay.